Cependant, l'approche d'Ola
de mesurer ce que nous savons a fait les grands titres,
et CNN a publié ces résultats sur leur site.
Ils ont mis les questions, des millions de gens ont répondu
et il y avait environ 2 000 commentaires,
celui-ci en était un.
Il disait : « Je parie qu'aucun membre des médias n'a réussi le test. »
Donc Ola m'a dit : « Prends ces appareils.
Tu es invité à des conférences de presse.
Donne-leur et mesure ce qu'ils savent. »
Et, mesdames et messieurs,
pour la première fois, les résultats informels
d'une conférence avec les médias américains.
Et ensuite, avec les médias de l'Union Européenne.
(Rires)
Le problème n'est pas que les gens
ne lisent pas ou n'écoutent pas les médias.
Le problème est que les médias n'en savent rien eux-mêmes.
Que pouvons-nous donc faire, Ola ?
A-t-on des idées ?
(Applaudissements)
Ola Rosling : Oui, j'ai une idée, mais d'abord,
je suis désolé que vous ayez été battu par les chimpanzés.
Heureusement, je peux vous réconforter
en vous montrant pourquoi, en fait, ce n'était pas de votre faute.
Ensuite, je vais vous donner quelques trucs
pour battre les chimpanzés.
Voilà ce que je vais faire.
Regardons pourquoi nous sommes si ignorants,
et tout commence ici.
C'est Hudiksvall, une ville dans le nord de la Suède.
C'est le quartier où j'ai grandi.
Et c'est un quartier avec un gros problème.
Le même problème
qu'il y a dans tous les quartiers,
comme ceux où vous avez grandi.
Ce n'était pas représentatif. Ok ?
Ça m'a donné une vision biaisée
de la vie sur cette planète.
C'est la première pièce du puzzle de l'ignorance.
Nous avons aussi des préjugés
Nous avons des expériences différentes
selon les communautés et les personnes rencontrées
et en plus, nous allons à l'école,
ce qui rajoute le prochain problème.
J'aime les écoles,
mais les profs enseignent des visions du monde dépassées,
suivant ce qu'eux ont appris à l'école,
et maintenant ils décrivent ce monde aux élèves,
sans mauvaises intentions,
et les livres sont, bien sûr,
aussi dépassés dans un monde qui change sans arrêt.
Il n'y a pas vraiment de méthodes
pour que le matériel scolaire soit à jour.
C'est ce sur quoi nous nous concentrons.
Nous avons donc ces données dépassées
ajoutées à nos propres préjugés.
Ensuite, nous avons les nouvelles.
Un bon journaliste sait comment
choisir une histoire qui fera la une,
et les gens la liront parce qu'elle est sensationnelle.
Les événements inhabituels sont plus intéressants, non ?
Et ils sont exagérés,
surtout les choses dont on a peur.
Un requin attaquant un Suédois
va faire la une pendant des semaines en Suède.
Il est donc très difficile de se détacher
de ces trois sources d'information biaisées.
En quelque sorte, ils nous bombardent
et dotent notre esprit d'idées étranges,
et en plus de ça, nous laissons de côté la chose
qui nous rend humain, notre intuition.
C'était utile pour l'évolution.
On a appris à généraliser
et arriver aux conclusions très, très vite.
Ça nous a aidé à exagérer ce qui nous faisait peur,
et nous cherchons une causalité là où il y en n'a pas,
et ensuite nous avons une illusion de confiance
où nous croyons être les meilleurs conducteurs,
au dessus de la moyenne.
Tout le monde dit
« Ouais, je conduis mieux. »
Ok, c'était bien sur le plan évolutionnaire,
mais quand il s'agit de notre vision du monde,
c'est la raison pour laquelle on ne comprend plus.
Les tendances qui augmentent sont plutôt en baisse,
et dans l'autre sens,
et dans ce cas-ci, les chimpanzés utilisent notre intuition contre nous,
et ça devient une faiblesse plutôt qu'une force.
C'était supposé être notre force, n'est-ce pas ?
Comment résoudre de tels problèmes ?
Premièrement, nous devons les mesurer,
pour ensuite les résoudre.
En les mesurant, nous pouvons comprendre
quel est le schéma de l'ignorance.
La phase pilote a commencé l'année dernière
et nous sommes sûrs que nous allons observer
beaucoup d'ignorance à travers le monde,
et l'idée est vraiment
de la mesurer dans tous les domaines
et toutes les dimensions du développement mondial,
tel que le climat, les espèces menacées, les droits de l'homme,
l'égalité des sexes, l'énergie, la finance.
Tous ces secteurs possèdent des données,
et certaines organisations essayent
de propager ces données.
En fait, j'en ai contacté quelques-unes,
comme WWF, Amnesty International et l'UNICEF,
en leur demandant quelles sont leurs données préférées
inconnues du grand public ?
J'ai rassemblé ces données.
Imaginez une longue liste, avec, disons, 250 données.
Puis, nous sondons le public
et regardons où ils échouent le plus.
Nous obtenons une liste plus courte
avec ces mauvais résultats
comme quelques exemples d'Hans,
et nous n'avons aucun problème à obtenir
ce genre de résultats.
Qu'allons-nous faire avec cette liste ?
Nous l'avons transformé en un certificat de connaissances,
un certificat de connaissances globales,
que vous pouvez utiliser, si vous êtes une grosse entreprise,
une école, une université, ou une agence de presse,
pour vous certifier en tant que bien informé sur le monde.
En gros, nous n'engageons personne
ayant un score de chimpanzé.
Bien sûr que vous ne devriez pas.
Dans 10 ans peut-être,
si ce projet réussi,
vous serez en entretien
et devrez répondre à ce questionnaire fou sur vos connaissances mondiales.
Passons aux astuces pratiques.
Comment allez-vous faire pour réussir ?
Il y a, bien sûr, une manière,
qui est de veiller tard le soir
et d'apprendre toutes ces données par cœur
en lisant tous ces rapports.
Bien sûr, ça n'arrivera jamais.
Même Hans n'y croit pas.
Les gens n'ont pas le temps.
Les gens aiment les raccourcis, et les voici.
Nous devons refaire de notre intuition une force.
Nous devons pouvoir généraliser.
Je vais vous montrer quelques trucs
où les idées fausses sont transformées
en règles de base.
Commençons avec la première idée fausse.
Elle est très répandue.
Tout s'aggrave.
Vous l'avez entendu et y pensez vous-même.
L'autre façon de penser est la plupart des choses s'améliorent.
Vous êtes assis, face à une question,
et vous n'êtes pas sûr. Vous devez deviner « améliorer. »
Ok ? N'optez pas pour le pire.
Ça vous servira à mieux réussir nos tests.
(Applaudissements)
C'était le premier truc.
Il y a les riches et les pauvres
et le fossé s’agrandit.
C'est une inégalité horrible.
Oui, c'est un monde inégal,
mais quand on regarde les données, c'est une bosse.
Ok ? Si vous n'êtes pas sûr,
optez pour « la majorité des gens sont au milieu. »
Ça vous aidera à avoir la bonne réponse.
L'idée préconçue suivante est
que les pays et les gens doivent d'abord être très très riches
avant de pouvoir se développer socialement,
de scolariser les filles et de pouvoir faire face aux catastrophes naturelles.
Non, non, non. C'est faux.
Regardez cette énorme bosse au milieu,
ici, les filles sont déjà scolarisées.
Donc si vous n'êtes pas sûrs, optez pour
« la majorité a déjà ça, »
comme l’électricité, les filles scolarisées, et ces choses-là.
Ce ne sont que des règles de base,
bien sûr elles ne s'appliquent pas à tout,
mais c'est comme ça que vous pouvez généraliser.
Regardons la dernière.
Si quelque chose, oui, c'est un bon exemple,
les requins sont dangereux.
Non. Enfin, si, mais ils ne sont pas si importants
dans les statistiques globales, c'est ce que je dis.
J'ai en réalité très peur des requins.
Donc en voyant une question à propos des choses qui m'effrayent
ça peut être des tremblements de terre, d'autres religions,
peut-être que j'ai peur des terroristes ou des requins,
tout ce qui m'effraie,
supposez que vous allez exagérer le problème.
C'est une règle de base.
Bien sûr, il y a des choses dangereuses qui sont aussi importantes.
Les requins tuent peu de gens. C'est comme ça que vous devez penser.
Avec ces 4 règles de base,
vous pourrez mieux répondre que les chimpanzés,
parce qu'eux ne peuvent pas faire ça.
Ils ne peuvent pas généraliser ce type de règles.
En espérant pouvoir changer votre monde
et ainsi battre les chimpanzés. Ok ?
(Applaudissements)
C'est une approche systématique.
Maintenant la question : est-ce important ?
Oui, c'est important de comprendre la pauvreté,
l'extrême pauvreté et comment la combattre,
et comment scolariser les filles.
En réalisant que c'est efficace, nous pouvons le comprendre.
Mais est-ce important pour les autres,
ceux qui se soucient de ce côté riche de cette échelle ?
Je dirais oui, extrêmement important,
pour la même raison.
Si vous avez une vision du monde basée sur des faits,
vous avez une chance de comprendre
ce qui arrivera dans le futur.
Revenons à ces deux bosses en 1975.
C'est l'année où je suis né,
et j'ai sélectionné l'Occident.
C'est les pays actuels de l'U.E. et l'Amérique du Nord.
Regardons maintenant comment le reste et l'Occident se comparent
en termes de richesse.
Il y a des personnes qui peuvent se permettre de
prendre l'avion pour aller à l'étranger en vacances.
En 1975, seulement 30% d'eux vivaient
en dehors de l'U.E. et de l'Amérique du Nord.
Mais ça a changé.
D'abord, regardons le changement jusqu'à aujourd'hui, en 2014.
Aujourd'hui c'est 50/50.
La domination occidentale n'est plus, à compter d'aujourd'hui.
C'est bien. Et que se passe-t-il ensuite ?
Vous voyez cette grosse bosse ? Vous voyez comment elle se déplace ?
J'ai fait un test. Je suis allé sur le site du Fonds Monétaire International.
Ils font des prévisions sur 5 ans du PIB par habitant.
Je les utilise pour avancer de 5 ans dans le futur,
en supposant que l'inégalité des revenus de chaque pays reste le même.
Je l'ai fait et je suis allé encore plus loin.
J'ai utilisé ces 5 ans pour les 20 prochaines années
avec la même vitesse, simplement pour observer ce qui pourrait arriver.
Avançons dans le futur.
En 2020, c'est 57% dans le reste.
En 2025, 63%.
2030, 68%. Et en 2035, l'Occident est dépassé sur le marché de la richesse.
Ce ne sont que des projections de PIB par habitant dans l'avenir.
73% des consommateurs riches
vivront en dehors de l'Amérique du Nord et de l'U.E.
Donc oui, c'est une bonne idée que les entreprises utilisent ce certificat
afin de s'assurer que leurs décisions soient basées sur des faits dans le futur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Hans et Ola Rosling ! Merci !